when we talk about the solar system we
have a standard image of it in our
mind's eye
there is the sun and the eight planets
orbiting it
but in reality the size of our system is
by far greater than we're able to
picture
and the number of celestial bodies
within its boundaries is staggering
the further from the earth we explore
the harder it is to find out about the
properties of objects we encounter
one of these objects is augus a dwarf
planet candidate
located in the fascinating kuiper belt
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
but before we look at it i'd like to
tell you that we're now in telegram
if you are keen on all sorts of bizarre
phenomena around us
and would like to enjoy more updates
you're welcome to subscribe
the link is in this video's description
and now back to the story
the kuiper belt is an area in the solar
system stretching from neptune's orbit
to a point 55 astronomical units away
from the sun
in many ways it resembles the asteroid
belt
but in contrast the kuiper belt is 20
times as wide
and approximately a hundred times as
massive for the most part it is made up
of small bodies
basically debris of material left after
the formation of the solar system
unlike the asteroid belt objects
celestial bodies in the kuiper belt
consist for the most part of volatile
elements
like methane and water there are at
least
four officially confirmed dwarf planets
in this
area and it is here the talcus was
discovered
the object was spotted on the 17th of
february 2004 by american astronomers
michael brown
chad trujillo and david rabinowitz
the scientists were able to distinguish
it in some archive images
taken back on the 8th of november 1951
now let's take a closer look at it
orcas is a large transneptunian object
of the plutino category
apart from orcas other celestial objects
of this category
include pluto ixion and who you are
objects like that are locked in a two to
three resonance with neptune
which means that when a plutino orbits
the sun twice
neptune orbits it three times in the
same period
the furthest point from the sun
regularly reached by orcas
is 48 astronomical units and the closest
it ever gets to the sun is 30
astronomical units
orcas diameter supposedly measures 946
kilometers
which is approximately 40 percent that
of pluto
its surface temperature is 229 degrees
celsius below
zero it is largely thanks to orcas's
moon discovered in february 2007 that
scientists are able to have clearer
ideas about orcas's properties
the discovery of the moon was michael
brown's achievement too
and the object was dubbed vanth it takes
vanth
nine and a half days to complete one
full orbit around
orcas the distance between them is nine
thousand kilometers
it is posited that orcas and valve are
in synchronous rotation
that is they face each other at all
times with the same sides
pluto and its satellite keran are locked
in the same manner
vance diameter is estimated at
approximately 280 kilometers
and the object's orbit around august is
practically circular
however these parameters for both vanth
and dawkis are still
admittedly not very accurate at this
point
wants mass may account for three to
seven and a half percent of the total
mass
of both objects as we've mentioned
before
vanth is just nine thousand kilometers
away from orcas
which is too close for its surface
composition to be spectroscopically
analyzed
it is suggested however that vanth may
have been captured from the kuiper belt
at some point
the total mass of vanthan darkest is 3.8
percent that of aries
one of the most massive dwarf planets
known today
but the way the mass is distributed
between august and its satellite
depends on the ratio of their sizes
investigations of orchestra spectrum
found
that the signal absorption by water eye
stair is the strongest among hyperbelt
objects not related to the haumea family
large uranium satellites have a similar
spectrum
among other trans-neptunian objects it
is karen
pluto's satellite that resembles orcis
the most
they have similar density and water ice
was detected on the surfaces of both
orchesis spectrum differs a lot from
that of other trans-neptunian objects
red is to be found in ixion spectrum for
example
but infrared there is rather faint
orchestra's visible spectrum is of a
neutral faint hue
further infrared observations of orcas
confirmed that there is water ice and
carbonaceous compounds in its
composition
the parameters of orcis's orbit make one
think of those of pluto
in the past 14 000 years the distance
between orcish and neptune has never
been shorter than 18 astronomical units
and even though orcis's orbit almost
brushes that of neptune
the strong tilt does not allow the
objects get closer
the rotation period of orcas still
remains to be found
out photometric studies give rather
scattered results
from 7 to 21 hours
now let's take a look at its surface
which is comparatively bright
the ice discovered on it is for the most
part in crystals
which may be indicative of cryo-volcanic
activity
other compounds like methane or ammonium
may also be found in orcus
interestingly to date ammonium hasn't
been discovered on any trans-neptunian
object a rice moon save miranda
in addition models of internal heating
by thermonuclear fusion suggest the
talcus is able to sustain a subsurface
ocean
of liquid water since there are water
ice crystals and possibly ammonium ice
to be found
it may be indicative of renewal
mechanisms that may have been active on
orcas's surface in the past
cryovolcanism may well have been one of
these mechanisms
a single eruption may have taken place
on orcas at some point
turning amorphous water into ice
crystals
as for the origins of this celestial
body scientists are still at odds trying
to find an answer to this question
according to amy barr and meg schwamp
orcus may have been formed when some
celestial objects collided at a low
speed
there are also doubts as to what
category orcas falls into
today orcas is a possible dwarf planet
but this is just a suggestion that may
potentially be disputed
rather than a unanimous opinion apart
from orcas
there are at least 40 other similar
dwarf planet candidates known to science
today
and according to preliminary estimates
the number of possible dwarf planets in
the entire solar system which haven't
been discovered yet
may well exceed two thousand the number
of officially acknowledged dwarf planets
today
is six these are series hygeia
and transneptunian objects pluto aerys
makimaki and haumea and if you would
like me to tell you more about these
please let me know in the comments below
to qualify as a dwarf planet and to get
on the list of the acknowledged ones
august has to satisfy certain parameters
namely astronomers have to make sure
that firstly august orbits the sun
secondly that its mass is sufficient to
maintain a spherical shape
thirdly that it is not any planet's
satellite and last but not least
that it is not able to get rid of debris
it may come across
in its path at this point august comes
forth on the list of likely dwarf
planets
beaten only by the following celestial
objects
gong gong kwawa and 2002 ms4
let's look at the minoda gong gong is
one of the largest transneptunian
objects
and it was discovered on the 17th of
june 2007 by michael brown's team
its diameter supposedly measures 1535
kilometers
its mass is 75 percent bigger than that
of ceres
it is only slightly bigger than that of
kwawa
it has a moon called shang liu in its
orbit which is 15 000 kilometers away
from it and whose diameter is 300
kilometers
kwawa is a transniptunian object too
which may rightfully be called one of
the largest in the kuiper belt
just like gong gong it was also
discovered by michael brown's team
and it happened the same year the 2002
ms4 was added on the astronomical map
qawa's diameter is estimated at
approximately 1100 kilometers
it has a moon in its orbit with a
diameter of 74 kilometers
named weiwat 2002 ms4
is the third likely dwarf planet
candidate and according to some
estimates
it boasts a diameter of about 930
kilometers
all these celestial bodies including
orcas may be considered rather large
for ones in the kuiper belt their
parameters lead scientists to think them
very likely to be dwarf planets
which may mean that one of them will
probably be officially granted this
status very soon
it is also highly likely that it is
august that will make this new dwarf
planet in the solar system
but while it isn't the case yet this
celestial object remains to be figured
out
and its further exploration may reveal
new exciting evidence that is still
lying in store for it
you